c'est non non il est temps pour nous
d'écouter la voix vengeresse de la
société il va s'exprimer par l'organe ô
combien merveilleux o o
du procureur général de la république
des proches française
[Musique]
je vois la plus dure
e
eh bien monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les jurés tous les moyens
tous les i was yens ces pathologies
c'est tout ce public chéri ainsi nous
vous tenons charles aznavour et vous
allez payer
j'ai déjà fait c'est pas fini voyez cet
homme mesdames et messieurs les jurés
voyez comme il a peur actuellement peur
de la robe austère de la justice sous
laquelle mesdames et messieurs les
radicaux voire des bons de monsieur le
président si on faisait le bilan de tout
ce qui se cache sous la robe aux sternes
justice depuis pau fait l'émission dure
est de couvrir un grand magasin
d'instruments aratoires a certes ce
n'est pas à la baisse il il a la tête
sur les épaules disons qu'il a encore la
tête sur les épaules merci la cour dans
son immense mansuétude
car vous êtes bon monsieur le président
mon p'tit claude
permettez que je vous appelle mon
président mon p'tit claude lacour dijon
dans son hymne infinie mansuétude
motoriste elle a illustré d'une amusante
anecdote personnelle ce rude
réquisitoire contre charles aznavour
réfléchissez avant de répondre monsieur
pouvait répondre oui non ne sait pas ou
qu'est ce que ça peut te [ __ ] tepa de
la police vas-y nous ennuie pas trop
longtemps bien c'était donc c'était
samedi dernier aux alentours de minuit
je venais de passer la soirée chez une
amie qui fait très bien les piperade
c'est un mois
m
j'avais la gorge un peu sèche
ah oui c'est le problème avec les
pirates
tiens me dis je soudain pourquoi
irais-je points à boire un coup chez
régine moi qui suis snob et qu'on
designers vous n'êtes pas snob
régine je le précise à l'intention de
nos amis que le soignant qui n'ont pas
la chance
là
qui n'ont pas la chance d'avoir les
couleurs et d'habiter paris
d'ailleurs généralement c'est les même
si on bat paris dans les creux régine
c'est le nom du dancing boum boum
parisiens tenus par la chanteuse du même
nom alors on y côtoie plus souvent le
gratin que les marchands de pommes de
terre si vous voyez ce que je veux dire
il existe à paris d'ailleurs une bonne
dizaine de trip hop on peut de ce genre
on a intérêt à montrer patte blanche si
possible manucure et d'ailleurs en
échange de quoi vous pouvez y retrouver
votre bouteille personnel avec votre nom
sur l'étiquette
alors quand le larbin copains parce qu
on est copain avec les l'armagnac au
kosovo mais peuvent gauche tous une
grande famille quand le larbin copains
vous voit arriver
eagle la bouteille à monsieur chazot la
bouteille hammam 50 la bouteille à soeur
thérésa et c'est une grande joie pour
tous ces gens du tout paris surtout
quand ils arrivent à cet âge incertain
où l'on hésite encore entre le cancer et
l'infarctus
c'est une grande joie simple d'avoir sa
bouteille avec son nom sur l'étiquette
c'est un vrai plaisir de riches surtout
si l'on songe que les pauvres eux pour
avoir leurs bouteilles avec leur nom sur
l'étiquette
ils sont obligés d'en passer par
l'analyse d'uriné et on serait pour
savoir avec quoi
on essaie mais ses ministres et
l'analyse du rythme sieste avant même si
l'on tient compte du fait qu'elle est
gratuite dans la plupart des
établissements de l'assistance publique
même si on tient compte du fait qu'on a
envie quelquefois de faire pipi
l'analyse du rin constituent-elles
vraiment un plaisir même si l'infirmière
est jolie mais si elle d'abord puis
c'est là d'un bien mais j'aimais gare de
lyon de toulouges et de charlesbourg
donc je vais chez régine et en arrivant
chez régine je tombe nez à nez avec son
époux qui avait l'air soucieux
qu'as-tu wenceslas mon qu'érige suis pas
sûr que ça va être ça se passe ça a pas
l'air d'aller
bof c'est ma femme me dit il du la vue
bah oui je la vois je vois régime
qu'est ce qu'elle a à sa femme peint
elle est pas terrible qui trouvent pas
et moi voulons être aimable pourrait
conforter cet homme malheureux je dis
bien sûr elle est pas belle mais il y en
a beaucoup
c'est là que je voulais revenir mesdames
et messieurs les jurés
charles aznavour contrairement à régine
il est pas beau mais en plus il y en a
pas beaucoup
or mesdames et messieurs les jurés notre
devoir est de demander à la cour de
raccourcir charlas à vos bons joueurs
demandent est ce bien raisonnable de
raccourcir un homme déjà six petits qui
peut même pas jouer au football sans
rigoler dans le gazon le château où il
se fait pas d'erreur
autant vous regarde charles aznavour on
peut s'empêcher de se demander comment
autant de génie peux te dire aussi peu
de place coincé entre une touffe d'un
plan et vert de talent e mail de quoi
testons qu'on pourrait dire vous accusez
pour parler comme le débris comme ce
débris du barreau rab aubry qui va
défendre rationnement ta gueule toi
d'abord charles aznavour vous avez vos
papiers d'arménie
je signale au il a osé
je signale à la cour que l'accusé
d'origine arménienne et qui sont en
complet et das neves orient j'ai déjà
dit c'est comme rien cacher mais dormait
quand vous parlez moi j'ai repris mon
nom je vous interdis de mon rapport sur
moi mais enfin c'est un nom n'est pas
complet c'est comme le mort de boris
vous sans vrai nom c'est boris vian ou
comme la province le morne et ans
c'est comme perfide immo à part ça j'ai
presque fini puisque s'inquiètent
vous êtes né le 24 mai 1924 22 manisa
124 excusez moi quatre ans plus tard en
1928 la récolte de bordeaux est
exceptionnel donc charles aznavour vous
êtes né en 1924
cinq ans plus tard en 1929 on entend
toujours pas parler d'eux ou alors que
le maréchal pétain lui il est pas encore
maréchal mais ils entrent déjà à
l'académie française où la batterie
l'acclamant héros pour le remercier une
fois de plus d'avoir dirigé la plus
importante boucherie en gros du
département de la meuse en 1916 à verdun
j'en ai terminé mon charles aznavour je
demande qu'on lui coupe une mèche ça
suffira pour pétain j'exige le retour de
ses cendres mme penchard
non c'est non non
[Musique]